[Music]
how's fatherhood going great
great we had a that's all the time we
have
we had a know you this will be worth the
wait we had a birthday party for my son
is five years old yes and my parents
even flew out for that when my parents
are in their 80s and they just love him
so much and they've been married for 61
years my parents and they still hold
hands they still hold hands but I think
that's to keep from falling over to be
on but we had a good time you know it's
hard to plan a party for five you know
you had a five year old right you still
there's a little bit of them yeah it's
like having a Prius it was underpowered
so no I now have an eight year old a
girl and a six year old boy okay so
they're growing that's a guy who so
doesn't care no I do care uh-huh I do
care what'd I just say
but not here so anyway so we have the
birthday party but it's hard to plan a
party for a five-year-old I think you
both agree with me on that
all right nobody agrees but you know you
have to plan it around their nap and so
he's at two o'clock right then I had to
find out what all his friends at school
took their naps and then I you know I
had to find out what my parents nap
which is most of the day and and then I
power nap at three o'clock every day so
I had a plan and when he would be awake
at the same everybody would be awake at
the same time so we had the party at
7:00 in the morning
Wow he served coffee I thought we had
coffee yeah that was a good question
weeds air Sunday nights at 10:00 on
Showtime a lot of people wish the show
would be around even longer but because
it's beloved to be loved show people
love this show but you know what what
you got to go out on the top and we
missed that well it's a great show
people love it
and we're so grateful to the fans yeah
blah blah blah and his stand-up special
Kevin Nealon whelmed but not overly do
be use August 4 that's gonna be short
I'm Kevin Nealon funny one of my
favorite people thank you so much
[Applause]